can supporting charities help your
business so I got a question from one of
my YouTube viewers floridian three three
nine three six love you guys we're gonna
say I would like to know your thoughts
about how besides networking events
getting involved in charities he'll help
promote and grow and starting a new
business best wishes from Germany Lars
so large this is a great question my
belief with this one just like an every
other business decision is you should be
doing it to do it you should be getting
involved with the charity because the
charity does something that brings you
alive is contributing to a goal that you
strongly believe in and not just see it
as a marketing opportunity for your
business if that's all you see then
don't do it because it's not worth it it
has to be something that you feel
passionate about if it is then
connections will happen you know you'll
get along well with the board and
they'll send you new business and you'll
meet people at the events and you know
maybe you donate stuff then you get
promoted on their website like all this
will happen but it but it only happens
if you were really passionate about it I
got a question a while ago from a guy
was open a retail store he said he
thought he walked by these homeless
people every day on the way to work and
was wondering if he should support them
and feed them and whether he should talk
about that in his business or not and I
said listen you know if this is
something that is important to you
feeding homeless people then do it like
don't care what your customers saying
don't don't care if it's a marketing
thing or not do because it's the right
thing to do do because you feel
passionate about it and if people you
know homelessness is a tough issue
because a lot of people you know they
may not support that saying well you're
you know I don't think we'll get a job
why are you feeding them maybe you don't
want those people at your customer you
know like you want to be around people
who believe the same thing that you do
and so he ended up going ahead and doing
it before I released the video for him
and he said it worked out great you know
he feels better most important he feels
better he feels like he's doing
something important and contributing
back to society but also by showcasing
it in his store customers are also going
out and doing it and they're feeling
better and they feel more can
to him because now this company stands
for something right it has a soul it's
more than just buying I forget what he
sold buying flowers are fine red or
whatever it was right it stands for
something greater so didn't just for the
marketing don't do it it's not gonna
work won't help you but if you're doing
because it's the right thing to do then
you're gonna get some great results from
it and you should totally go for it I'm
involved with a charity called Kiva and
it basically helps raise funds for
entrepreneurs we select Africa we're
trying to start their business and we've
helped over 4,000 entrepreneurs now
start the business and that's something
I'm really proud of and I talk about it
every now and then I've gotten some
connections and some results from Kiva
but it doesn't matter right like I'm
doing it because I think it's important
to do I'm doing it because it makes me
feel good to be able to help those
people out I don't blast sound on my
homepage and say hey look at me I've
supported 4,000 entrepreneurs and gave
them money to start their company and
yet I've gotten some great results from
it gotten some contracts and gotten some
connections and cut some deals because
of something that I believe in and I'm
excited enough so hopefully I answered
your question large I always just do the
right thing I always do what feels good
what feel you know what what's in your
your heart what you're passionate about
and even though it may not make sense
right now you have to trust that the
dots will connect and it's all gonna
work out those you're watching like the
video give it a thumbs up below you have
a question you have a comment you want
me to feel better
leave a comment underneath click on my
face to subscribe to the channel thank
you so much LLC's